switching carriers can be both exciting
and daunting especially if you're eyeing
the rapidly growing field of cloud
computing the cloud computing industry
is booming and businesses across the
globe are increasingly moving their
operations to the cloud now this means
that cloud computing professionals are
high in demand and it's an excellent
time to switch your career to this field
however before you take the plunge it's
essential to understand what cloud
computing is and what you need to do to
switch to this field so here's a new
video by simply learn on how to switch
career to cloud computing to help you if
you are considering a career switch to
cloud computing so let's get started but
before that do subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the Bell icon to never
miss an update from Simply loan so
moving on here's a roadmap to help you
get started first is to identify your
goals now the first step is to identify
your career goals and aspirations in
cloud computing determine what kind of
cloud computing job you want to pursue
and which cloud computing platforms
interests you this will help you narrow
down your focus and choose a specific
area to specialize in
next is to get certified now cloud
computing is a highly technical field
and having the right certification can
set you apart from the competition
consider getting certified in popular
cloud computing platforms such as AWS
Azure or Google Cloud these
certifications demonstrate your
expertise in specific areas of cloud
computing and increase your
employability now to help you with this
step we have a Caltech post tragic
program in cloud computing this course
will help you become an expert in Azure
AWS and gcp
your master key architectural principles
and develop the skills needed to become
a cloud expert now this post graduate
program in cloud computing helps you
become an expert in designing planning
and scaling Cloud implementations our
cloud computing course helps you master
the core skill sets required to design
and deploy dynamically scalable and
reliable applications on completion of
this course you will gain caltex ctme
post graduate certificate with 40 plus
Hands-On projects along with the
opportunities to secure a job in large
companies like Netflix MasterCard Adobe
and more you can check out its Link in
the description following that you need
to build your skills now cloud computing
is a constantly evolving field and
staying up to date with the latest
Technologies and Trends is crucial
attend training sessions take online
courses or enroll in a certification
program to develop your skills in cloud
computing additionally build your
technical skills by gaining hands-on
experience with cloud computing
platforms through projects or
internships this will not only enhance
your resume but also provide you with
the Practical experience and insights in
the field our Catholic postgraduate
program will also help you learn skills
like Cloud provide the selection
application migration performance
testing Cloud workloads identity access
management Auto scaling and many more to
learn more about these skills and tools
you can check out the course link
mentioned in the description and then is
to gain work experience now to break
into cloud computing gaining work
experience is vital consider taking an
entry level position or internship in
cloud computing to build your skills and
gain exposure to real world scenarios
additionally leverage your existing
experience and skills to find
opportunities in cloud computing related
to your current field now next and the
final step is to create an impressive
resume your resume is the first
impression you make on potential
employers so make it count highlight
your technical skills relevant work
experience and certification in cloud
computing additionally tailor your
resume to the specific job you're
applying for and include any relevant
projects or achievements in conclusion
switching your career to cloud computing
requires dedication and effort but it's
a rewarding and lucrative feel by
following these steps you can prepare
yourself for a successful career in
cloud computing so just to cheer you up
more here's a success story of one of
others do have a look
I am currently living
I also realized that to get a new job I
needed to have a professional
certification in cloud computing so last
year I started the postgraduate program
in cloud computing in association with
Caltech concept video with this course I
had the choice to study while I
continued with my job and that is how I
put this new job offer with 60 percent
salary high in Finland I will be leading
the cloud computing unit of my new film
cutting we cannot wait to start our new
life in Finland we are also excited well
this was all about how to switch careers
to cloud computing I hope you enjoyed
this video and found it informative
please give it a thumbs up and share it
with your friends also if you have any
questions related to this video then
please feel free to ask in the comment
section our team will reach out to you
as soon as possible thank you and keep
learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here